là bonjour vous avez bien compris le
club d'aujourd'hui n'est pas anodin
puisque on va faire une vidéo fact sur
de vrais faux en rapport avec le
mentalisme avec amics m je suis allé à
angers précisément pour aller faire ça
mais à la fin de cette vidéo amics homme
va devoir répondre à trois questions roi
questions personnelles qu'il aura le
droit à un ou deux jokers pour lui un
joker ce sera la possibilité de mentir
et forcément ce sera à vous de
déterminer quand est ce qu a mixé moment
où quand est ce qu'il ne manque pas mais
dans un premier temps on va se
téléporter chez lui ah bah oui ça a pris
tellement ils savaient pas ouais et eux
non plus il t'avait pas vu dans le titre
ni sur la vignette mise en descriptions
ah oui non il avait à l'époque premier
acte plus on bâille longtemps plus ça
veut dire qu'on a un gros cerveau alors
moi j'ai lu un livre assez géniale qui
s'appelle votre ca au cf notre vidéo
quand on bâille ce qu'on est fatigué
juste apprendre un truc assez fou coucou
c'est un espèce de mécanismes
automatiques qui fait qu'on a besoin
d'air en fait beaucoup de bien pour y
offrir l'accès n'est en fait pas ça du
coup ça n'a rien à voir avec la taille
c'est faux et bien c'était complètement
ouvrez et bien ça fait complètement
chier c'est qu'on est fatigué parce que
notre cerveau est en surchauffe aux
accents rock du terme d'accor et donc
plus tu inspires d'air qui va le
refroidir et donc si tu as un gros
cerveau tu as besoin de faire un appel
d'air beaucoup plus grand crayon ou un
tuteur je vais faire des siennes à voir
comme au géant a vécu aussi si c'est un
crayon jeune attaquant ça si c'est un
leader je les graver sur la table
suivant le cerveau est l'organe le plus
gros de notre corps ah non le plus gras
j'écris très mal c'était très compliqué
comme question j'étais en mode les
poumons l'air il a compté je sais pas
non c'est faux c'est faux oui évidemment
que c'est vrai c'était mon équipe et moi
c'est en fait il est gras à 60% 60% du
cerveau c'est du gras suivant on utilise
seulement 17,3 pour cent de notre
cerveau ça me paraît très crédible comme
stade c'est vrai et bien c'est faux
alors non mais c'est faux mais chez un
peu bâtard parce que il ya une légende
urbaine qui dit qu'on n'utilise que 10%
de notre cerveau mais ça c'est
complètement faux d'accord et je suis je
vais je vais lui faire un facteur peu
fou aussi mais avec un chiffre très
précis mais oui pourquoi 17 qui a pu
prouver ça avec mes personnages je suis
ta bile
mais si on n'utilise jamais 100% de
notre cerveau en même temps quand on
utilise sans entrain de les avoir tous
mais exactement sait jamais en même
temps les risques suivants on peut
apprendre des données en les écoutant
durant son sommeil
alors si c'est fou je suis très déçu moi
j'avais fait ça une fois en plus j'avais
lu mon cours et je l'avais enregistré
sur le t3 je l'avais écouté en dormant
ça avait duré dix minutes je n'avais pas
dormir mais dans la théorie c'est
tellement bien tu te dit vas-y j'ai pas
réviser pendant la nuit je vais réviser
grâce à l'école devrait s'intégrer
inconsciemment
eh bien je dis que c'est vrai c'est faux
mais merde si c'est une légende urbaine
mais je pense que si vraiment ça
marchait depuis longtemps on le saurait
on aurait des nous vendrait des
cassettes des cassettes [ __ ] les mecs
et de 1982 c'est mon coach france
amateur goldsman et pour apprendre à
l'époque où j'y croyais et je m'étais
fait une cassette automne hiver ce
walkman tarifs pour essayer d'apprendre
comme ça bon je vais commencer à
réfléchir à partir de maintenant
suivant en 2015 un puissant
superordinateur eu besoin de 40 minutes
pour simuler une seconde activité du
cerveau humain c'est vrai c'est
totalement vrai yes
mais oui c'est très intéressant cette
vidéo abonnez vous suivant la longueur
des terminaisons nerveuses d'un adulte
fait 5 8 millions de kilomètres ce
chiffre est extrêmement précis dont
c'est mon téléphone allô c'est raccord
avec le walkman donc à temps c'est tout
les terminaisons nerveuses d'un être
humain d'un adulte mis bout-à-bout ou à
fait singulière de 8 millions de
kilomètres non non c'est beaucoup c'est
faux et bien c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai ces superbes vêtements vrai et ça
fait 5 45 fois le tour de la terre c'est
incroyable nous ne faisons pas cela qui
polit car suivant vous fait vous faut un
élève a hypnotisé un professeur à son
oral sa veste une dictée c'est faux je
te dis fabien statistiquement samedi que
ce soit arrivé
un mec qui feinte qui fore ya un sermon
dû le faire au moins une fois je te
comptabilise le verse le potentiellement
ça a pu arriver on ne le sait pas voilà
je vous en fait dû se trouver des
failles que suivant la bosse des maths
existe réellement physiquement la bosse
des maths c'est faux pour toi c'est faux
c'est chier et bien c'est faux yes c'est
faux s'est posé complètement fou que ça
date d'une époque où on faisait de la
phrénologie d'accord la phrénologie
c'est une pseudoscience où tu accélères
quelques mois des frais et des tu
freines menace et s était une pseudo
science mais qu'est vraiment le mec
avait lancé ça comme une science
il s'appelait france gall rien à voir
avec la chanteuse meilleures anecdotes
de la vidéo suivant un cheval mentalist
a arnaqué tout un pays
un cheval mentalist ouais donc le gars
de profession fallu le cas de profession
cheval mentale et de hobby mentalist
arnaquer tout un pays mais j'ai très
envie de dire que c'est vrai tellement
c'est improbable pourquoi tu réécris un
truc si improbable sinon bien sûr que
c'est vrai j'en ai même fait une vidéo
que vous pouvez retrouver en cliquant
sur red fish ici ou ici que je n'ai pas
vu du courbet peu de monde la vie ça
date de l'année dernière plus vers le
lancement de la chaîne
suivant le programme stargate a vraiment
existé cuivre de deux choses plus
légères qui ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
porte des étoiles à exister donc selon
toi mais fabien statistiquement magasins
agences spatiales qui sait dire est ce
que tu as accès à tous les dossiers
déclassifiés classifiés un bien c'est
vrai
tafer reyes en 1995 la cia faisait des
recherches sur la manipulation mentale
et sa série appelée stargate le projet
stargate donc là rien à voir mais
l'essai sur la manipulation mentale
c'est pour ça que c'est comme ça les
portes ils ont été déclassifiés en 2017
suivant il ya autant d'appareils
connectés à internet dans le monde que
deux neurones dans un cerveau d'ailleurs
comme ça qu'ils se font des attaques par
déni de service mais qui à 10 milliards
d'appareils connectés
donc ouais ça sonne bien de neuro de ça
c'est vrai c'est faux merde c'est pas
combien il ya de ne rentrer dans un
cerveau qu'on n'a jamais compté mais ça
n'a jamais quand et non on sait avant on
disait qu'elle est 100 milliards
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est moins on
dit qu'il ya 86 milliards donc entre 86
milliard et cent milliards de neurones
dans un camp même du manège fois plus là
on est on est bien bien loin suivant
giordano bruno ont chanté connaît non et
bien c'est le scientifique qui a réussi
à convaincre l'église que l'univers est
un film qu il y a dû prendre des risques
qu'il a réussi à les convaincre que
l'univers était un film est surtout un
petit singe qui souriaient à la fin du
world art
bien sûr il aurait il été bon c'est faux
très bien c'est faux si pour ces faux
alors c'est pas dur dano ses six filles
effectivement essayé de convaincre
l'église et tout le monde que le sida
continue où il s'est fait brûler ce qui
me semblait ah ben ça pouvait pas fêter
bien ce truc simple que ça suivant le
mot robot a été inventé en 1920 par les
premiers intelligence artificielle pour
se nommer elle même ce serait tellement
nous y habituer quoi je suis à robot en
1922 1920 précisément c'est la note et
précis c'est faux ça c'est faux si tu
complètement fou parce que la classe est
complètement faux mais en 1920 il ya une
pièce de théâtre aux tchèques de karel
capek qui représentait en fait des
travailleurs artificielle d'accord tu
vois qu'il y en ait qui était un peu
humanoïdes ailleurs qui faisait les
sages que celle de la science fiction
ouais c'est ça et avec des intelligences
artificielles et c'est lui qui a inventé
ça il appelait ça des robots tas ok ok
qui en tchèque veut dire servitude
d'accord et du coup le mot robot vient
de là
c'est très intéressant que la typologie
suivant une connexion entre deux
neurones ne disparaît jamais
naturellement ça doit bien les tentes
statistiquement est bien une petite
collection sur 10 milliards bon alors
voilà je peux pas vrai quand les 10
milliards qui tiennent et qu'elles
soient rompus que par l'alcool jeudi que
les connexions peuvent disparaître
autrement que dans l'alcool la drogue
naturellement oui c'est correct
je te pose trois questions tu vas devoir
dire la vérité à elle seule de ces trois
questions et vous vous devez chercher
sur les techniques que vous voulez quand
est ce qu'il dit la vérité
j'enlève minuad à un maximum de joueurs
on vous donnera la réponse sur twitter
décide de trois jours vous pouvez suivre
un mix entre le lien de sa chaîne de
toute manière exemplaire dans la
description et le lien de mon twitter de
la description où vous n'avez jamais
cliquer en haut c'est pas gentil mais on
vous donnera sa voix sur twitter dc dc
de trois jours première question oui
quel est ton plus gros mensonge tu peux
réfléchir un peu je alors le plus gros
mensonge que j'ai fait dans ma vie c'est
lorsque en fait j'étais à l'école
primaire et que j'ai mis le feu à
l'école et à l'école
ouais normal c'est vraiment une bonne
journée j'ai mis le feu à l'école et
j'ai menti à tout le monde donc copains
copines maîtresse maman finlande en
disant que c'était pas moi tu as plus
grosse honte c'est quand j'ai pris
discrètement en photo norman de norman
fait des vidéos et comme un fanboy et
qu'on m'a vu et c'était hyper gênant
j'ai totalement pris en scred comment
facebook vraiment le fanboy de base ne
va pas vu mais d'autres gens m'ont vu
c'était gênant truc le plus what the
fuck que tu en rapport avec youtube
alors un fact incroyable à propos de
youtube c'est que pour ceux qui
regardent la chaîne de cyril super
connard il a une porte secrète à sa
droite tu vois voilà et bien c'est parce
que quand tu lourd
c'est cette porte là et c'est mon studio
ça voudrait dire que c'est un studio
communs existent là c'est ça que ça
voudrait dire si mme hâtivement et peut
y avoir un couloir mais voilà que j'ai
vu en arrivant et qu'on a mangé tous en
chambre ce midi du coup ce serait
clairement se serait passé c'est ça
qu'est une vérité de mon sens il ya une
seule vérité dans le tas c'est ce que
vous devez trouver en fait
la vérité on arrive oui ça égalé encore
le feu tout est lié
je regarde ce qui me prend en photo on a
fait une vidéo ensemble cet été sur des
factures est faux mais sur nous oui si
oui et sur ta chaîne ou alors regarde
moi je connais très bien la vie à l'ewi
je ne sais jamais maintenant que je le
sais je le vois là j'adore l'utiliser
mais cette vidéo est très cool parce
qu'on apprend plein de choses sur toi et
même sur - oui tout à fait c'est une
sorte de faq vrai ou faux monde
chinoises et dans les commentaires en
plus de chercher ou escales mix m a dit
la vérité vous pouvez aussi me dire à
quel youtuber vous aimeriez que je fasse
ça ou sur quel autre sujet mais toujours
un port avec le mentalisme non c'est
vraiment marrer à faire ça moi le
premier donc si ça vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à me le dire en explosant la barre
des pouces en l'air
auquel cas je ferai d'autres vidéos sur
cette série merci encore à un mix m de
m'avoir reçu abonnez-vous à lui si ce
n'est pas encore fait et nous on se
retrouve toujours les mardis et les
vendredis à 15 heures et le dernier
mercredi du mois à 20h20 pour le live à
très bientôt chao pour grover vrai ou
faux en appuyant sur le cercle là qu'il
ya au centre avec avec ma photo
on peut s'abonner même depuis un
téléphone vrai ou faux le meilleur moyen
de le savoir c'est d'essayer de le faire
fait le coup ça vous serez
[Musique]